نو ايضا لهذا الخبر العاجل الذي ننقله على
شاشه الجزيره نقلا عن الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
اصابه 11د اسرائيليا في حادثتي دهس وطعن
في رعنانا شمال تلبيب وهذه هي الصور
الاوليه
ل ما يقول الاسعاف الاسرائيلي بانه اصابه
لاحد عش اسرائيليا في حادثتي دهس وطعن في
رعنانا شمال تل ابيب اذا هذا هو اخر
الاخبار العاجله نقلا عن للاسعاف
الاسرائيلي باصابه 11 اسرائيليا في حادثتي
دهس دهس وطعن في رعنانا شمال
تلبيب وهذه هي الصور الاوليه لسيارات
الاسعاف التي تنقل عدد من المصابين بحسب
ما يبدو في هذه الصور الاوليه اذا هناك
عمليه ما ل ادت الى اصابه هناك ارتفاع في
عدد الاصابات نقلا عن الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
بلغت 19 اسرائيليا بحادثي دهس وطعن في
رعنانا شمال تل ابيب اذا تطور لافت في هذه
اللحظات ونتحدث عن تلبيب وتحديدا في
شمالها في منطقه رعنانا وهناك اصابه ل 19
اسرائيليا حتى الان في حادثتي دهس و وطعن
هذه المعلومات الاوليه سنحاول بطبيعه
الحال النظر في
التفاصيل
ويبدو من هذه الصور نقل عدد من
المصابين لكن ما ما يثير الانتباه في هذه
الاخبار هو بان المكان الذي وقعت فيه هو
رعنانا شمال تل ابيب